welcome to cash cart closer to Baghdad
mr. Beijing the accusation from the
Chinese government is that Islamist
extremists are crossing those borders
and radicalizing the population here mr.
Sun saw it all who did it we asked
minorities he says Muslims
there are signs of a city on edge the
moment you arrive in a room Chi soldiers
in the shadows outside the mosques 2,000
miles to the west of Beijing this is a
place which feels not remotely Chinese
but where the grip of the Communist
Party is now stronger than ever
this old Silk Road City is the capital
of Xinjiang province home of the weekers
China's Muslims once it was all theirs
now there are minority here Chinese from
the rest of the country the hand have
moved in they don't live well together
three months ago this Street was a
bustling market stalls lining both sides
now it's deserted a lone trader
remembers the day everything changed
two cars drove up the street he says
explosives were thrown from the windows
43 people died this is a Han Chinese
part of town a community left stunned
mr. son saw it all who did it we asked
minorities he says
Muslims FEG
our taxi driver also han chinese goes
further echoing the government line
these he says the work of religious
fanatics from the south from the city of
cash colorful manga we leave our hotel
early the following morning the
government makes reporting from here
tricky we must move every day the flight
to kashgar is a little over an hour
this really is China's western frontier
welcome to cash cart closer to Baghdad
than it is to Beijing and the feel of
the Middle East is everywhere the look
the food the language
these are devout Muslims the Adyar
mosque is China's largest but
encroaching all around is the Chinese
influence the city is modernizing
ancient weaker homes are bulldozed tower
blocks increasingly dominate the skyline
whole communities of Han Chinese now
live here but entirely separately from
the weakest oh thank you
today shopping you enter the Chinese
shopping centers through metal detectors
bags are scanned
so what that is clearly is a drill this
is the Chinese part of town the Han
Chinese part of town they're very
concerned that there could be an attack
by wielders back in the old town we meet
a we go willing to talk most fear
government reprisals he tells me his
culture is being destroyed and his
religion restricted this is what he
means signs on the street corners
spelling out new policies here for
Muslims no veils no beards we discover
it causes considerable resentment at
night the military presence is intense
soldiers gather underneath the vast
statue of Chairman Mao a reminder of
who's in charge here at roadblocks
papers are checked phones are examined
for extremist material we move on early
the following morning we're heading
further south
beyond the snowy mountains his
Afghanistan
this is where the government's war on
terror is at its most intense and where
the truth is even harder to establish
woman less than 100 miles now from the
borders with Pakistan and Afghanistan
and the accusation from the Chinese
government is that Islamist extremists
are crossing those borders and
radicalizing the population here we
reach a suburb of yarkand County the
internet has been cut people's movement
restricted it's a place where the
government says it killed 96 terrorists
exactly a month ago we were exiled
claimed 2000 don't find out our driver
is too intimidated to stop and so as
this Chinese war on terror intensifies
so to Dazz the resentment if religious
extremists are among this population
their efforts to recruit her only been
made easier mark stone Sky News in
China's Xinjiang province